a man from daran kuyu in the nevershire
province of turkey was renovating his
basement using only a sledgehammer he
broke through one of his walls he felt
cool air coming in from the other side
when the hole was large enough to
squeeze through he decided to
investigate and inside he found a small
room-sized cave and at first he was
excited this could save him a lot of
work this area of turkey has a complex
cave system so he thought he
accidentally stumbled into one he didn't
when he turned on his flashlight he saw
writing on the walls roman greek and
languages he didn't recognize that first
small room was only the beginning
let's find out why
[Music]
flashlight in hand he followed the
narrow stone hallway at first glance
this looked like a natural cave
formation but upon closer inspection he
wasn't so sure the stone ceiling was
rough like you'd expect to see in a cave
but the walls were smooth over hundreds
or thousands of years an underground
river could have eroded away the stone
but there was something eerie about this
place it was if he could feel a human
presence the hallway continued for some
ways eventually spilling into a large
room that could fit dozens of people and
from here he found a system of
passageways and here and there were more
small rooms and some looked like storage
areas with crevices that could have
acted as shelves and around every corner
he found more rooms first he thought
this was some kind of hideout but it was
just too big nobody could have built
this so after exploring a few hours he
thought he finally reached the end of
the structure but after making a sharp
turn he saw actual carved stairs which
led down even further into the darkness
if there was any question before now it
was clear this wasn't a natural
structure it was built by people but it
was too massive for him to explore on
his own so when he made it back through
the hole in his basement wall he called
the turkish authorities and described
them what he'd found they told him he
was describing the myth of the hidden
city of daran kuyu and the man knew the
story well he'd heard it since he was a
boy the myth of darren cuyu talked of an
ancient city which provided refuge to
every citizen in the area built
thousands of years ago hidden beneath
the surface he knew the myth of daryn
kuyu very well he then said sir with all
due respect it's not a myth
[Music]
darren cuyu is in the cappadocia region
of central turkey which has very
distinct geology millions of years ago
volcanoes covered the area when ash is
ejected during a volcanic eruption it
solidifies into a type of rock called
tough and tough is a relatively soft and
porous rock found all over the region
well why the hell did they name soft
rock tuff well it comes from the latin
word tofus meaning
marketing sandstone should have needed
something like a
mushy rock
or easy chisel
we're not selling the stuff everything
is for sale my friend may i continue no
by all means
because tough is so pliable easy
it's been used for construction since
ancient times romans used it all over
the empire and the statues on easter
island are also made of tough so it's
not surprising that people in turkey
have been building with this material
since prehistory but rather than mine
the stone and build up the people in
daran kuyu built down there are hundreds
of subterranean houses in cappadocia and
some even go down two stories but
there's nothing quite like daran kuyu
the underground city of derenkuyu goes
down over 250 feet in the first few
years of exploration experts went 18
stories down and since then two more
levels have been discovered it might go
down even further archaeologists are
still excavating the total area of the
city discovered is five square miles or
13 square kilometers and housed over 22
000 people the upper floors were used as
apartments closest to the fresh air but
darren kuyu has a complex system of over
16 000 ventilation shafts that allow air
to circulate through every room in the
city it also has a fresh water supply at
the lowest levels of derenkuyu is a
series of underwater rivers and wells
were centrally located to bring water to
the entire city in fact people living on
the surface above daryn kuyu have been
using wells originally intended for the
underground city they just didn't
realize what was underneath them
incidentally darren kuyu is turkish for
deep well see that name makes sense
tough not so much you need to get past
the names pal yeah
the tunnels seem to go on forever to
walk from one end of darren cuyu to the
other is a seven kilometer walk or four
miles of tunnels as you move further
down the structure you'll find areas
that meet every need of a self-contained
city there are dining halls churches
schools there are rooms for pressing and
storing olive oil there are markets
bakeries wineries libraries and storage
for vast amounts of food a few more
levels down are areas for keeping
livestock
and stables for horses they're areas for
butchering curing and storing meat
thousands of people could survive for a
very long time completely underground
but who would build a giant subterranean
city and why
[Music]
the land in the cappadocia region of
turkey is extremely fertile ideal for
farming so why go through the trouble of
building such an elaborate underground
city well most archaeologists agree that
daran kuyu was built for protection but
it's more than a bunker it's an
underground fortress there are about 60
surface entrances to darin cuyu and
these doors are hidden in buildings and
courtyards and parks all over the town
but when the doors are closed they're
just part of the landscape and there was
only a single main entrance into the
city when under attack residents would
retreat underground using one of the
many hidden doors and the doorways were
protected by massive circular stones
that could retract and could only be
opened from the inside and these doors
weighed a thousand pounds each or more
and the main gate was even heavier the
access tunnels at the surface are very
narrow requiring people to enter single
file and this was intentional it would
force invaders into choke points to make
the city easier to defend and most
levels had armories to allow soldiers
and citizens easy access to weapons even
the local militia had dedicated stables
to maintain horses for a small cavalry
they could ride out through a secret
exit and take invaders by surprise and
derinkuyu's multi-level cave system
wasn't designed randomly it was well
thought out all of the city's levels are
interconnected but they could
individually be sealed off from one
another preventing enemies from going
any further into the structure or
sealing them in even the water supply
was designed with defense in mind it
could only be controlled by the bottom
up so if invaders breached the upper
levels their water would be cut off and
this system helped prevent the water
supply from being poisoned and as a last
resort there were dozens of hidden
passageways that led out of daran kuyu
and a passageway that leads to kaimakoli
another underground city that is about
four miles away and you can travel there
completely underground is that one a big
city too well kaimakoli is still being
excavated but some say it may turn out
to be even bigger than daryn kuyu it's
thought that there could be an entire
series of interconnected cities all
around this area completely underground
so we know why this huge subterranean
city was built but who built it well
that's where there's some disagreement
but we do have some clues
[Music]
so who built daryn kuyu well the
structure is made of stone so carbon
dating is no help but there are a few
theories some believe construction
started with the hittites between three
and four thousand years ago and a few
hittite artifacts have been recovered
which make this case the anatolian
hittites controlled a large portion of
asia minor reaching all the way to upper
mesopotamia and cappadocia and
derenkuyou were right in the middle of
hittite territory and this region of
turkey was a main corridor for trade so
in the ancient world whoever controlled
the trade routes would be able to impose
their will on the entire region location
location
that's right this was very desirable
real estate and hittite cities were
under constant attack from outside
forces and underground fortress would
have been very useful to protect this
land and its people the hittites had
enemies on all sides they were
constantly at war with the assyrians the
thracians and of course the egyptians
and the people that gave the hittites a
lot of trouble and may even have been
responsible for their eventual demise
for the virginians the phrygians
inhabited central western anatolia in
ancient times and were related to the
greeks we all know the story of the
midas touch the buffalo guy no midas was
a phrygian king who according to legend
could turn anything into gold i think he
also invented the muffler uh he didn't
some believe the phrygians constructed
or at least expanded and improved the
city of daran kuyu the virginian people
were talented engineers and architects
they undertook large complex building
projects all over their territory
considered some of the greatest builders
of the iron age the virginians had the
skill knowledge and ingenuity to create
an elaborate subterranean city several
of the rooms in daran kuyu have been
determined to be ancient chapels and on
the chapel walls are inscriptions
written in greek now the hittites
wouldn't do this but the virginians
would and they controlled the area until
about the 6th century bc when they were
conquered by the persians there are even
written records that may support this
xenophon of athens wrote anabasis in 370
bc documenting a greek army expedition
to persia he mentions a people in
anatolia and cappadocia who lived
underground in dwellings large enough
for entire families now though they
didn't build daran kuyu early christians
occupied it in the first century a.d
within the complex are several christian
churches and there are christian symbols
and writing all over the upper floors
they also added vaulted ceilings and
other structural features found in
christian architecture derenkuyo was a
place for christians to hide from roman
soldiers and practice their faith in
secret avoiding persecution from the
roman empire and during the arab
byzantine wars from 780 to 1180 muslim
arabs used daran kuyu they also expanded
the structure and inscribed the walls
now there's no consensus on who built
daran kuyu but its role in history is
undisputed it was a shelter from
attacking armies refuge from raiding
tribes and sanctuary to the faithful who
feared religious persecution i like to
think that if the first builders knew
how many thousands of people would use
this city to protect their faith and
their families those builders would be
proud
darren kuyu is an important discovery
and i hope it inspires others to explore
undiscovered secrets are all around us
now sometimes the walls that obscure the
truth are miles thick but other times
they're paper thin but whether by
innovation persistence or sheer luck
those walls can be breached it's at that
point that a wardrobe becomes a gateway
to narnia platform nine and three
quarters opens up a world of magic and a
few inches of stone in a humble turkish
basement reveals an ancient underground
city i encourage you to break down these
walls wherever you find them whether
it's a literal wall as in this story or
a wall in your mind holding you back
from an adventure break down that wall
you never know what hidden world you
might discover
[Music]
thanks so much for hanging out with me
today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share this
video those little things really help
the channel until next time be safe be
kind and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
do
you